that is a striking resemblance between
Larry King and Ruth Bader Ginsburg hey
legal eagles it's time to think like a
lawyer today I am outside of the eagle's
lair doing a live video from VidCon
although by the time that you watch this
it probably won't be live it'll be long
after VidCon I asked you guys to help
out and send in some legal memes that I
can comment and respond to and you guys
did not disappoint we got some great
legal memes to talk about today so it's
time for our very own meme review meme
review trademark of peopIe
all rights reserved alright so let's dig
into our very first legal meme review on
this channel alright what the defendant
tell the court exactly what kind of
whale are you well i'm objection oh my
god it's a dolphin defending a killer
whale but the prosecutor is a seal
because killer whales kill seals oh
that's kind of sad but also hilarious
you know you gotta be careful sometimes
even things like names to be more
prejudicial than probative and they are
not allowable in court how you feel when
the jury laughs at your joke and it's
Joe Pesci not wearing an endo Chino suit
by the way so you always want to build
up a rapport with the jury and when you
have a joke that lands with the jury or
the judge it is a really really great
feeling although it is in contrast to
when the judge makes a joke in court
you're basically obligated to laugh
whether the joke is funny or not and all
Federal Court judges think that they are
just absolutely the funniest people on
Planet I hereby sentence you to sixty
eight years in prison me whispers to my
lawyer
my client has requested you add one
board here nice lawyer my client is
trapped inside a penny judge what lawyer
he's innocent judge you're going to jail
with him yeah well that's what happens
when you make a joke and the judge
doesn't laugh
the defense lawyer attack lawyer I place
one lawyer facedown and end my turn you
are a witness that's got to be a board
game or something
oh I'm sad that I don't recognize that I
feel like I'm pretty well versed in
board games is that a Dungeons & Dragons
thing let me know in the comments when
the partner tells you to hurry up and
finish that assignment oh my god
that hits so close to home sometimes you
have a deadline and you just can't spend
hours and hours working on a beautiful
finished masterpiece of a brief and
sometimes Managing Partner comes in and
tells you that you have exhausted all of
your time you just have to get it done
and that basically turns an amazing
legal brief into the converting picture
of a cheetah into the mascot for Cheetos
but sometimes getting it done is more
important than getting it perfect
according to multiple sources Ruth Bader
Ginsberg died six months ago and Larry
King has been standing in for her ever
since No ah that is not cool but that is
a striking resemblance between Larry
King and Ruth Bader Ginsburg that being
said everyone knows Ruth Bader Ginsburg
is never going to die
she has an exercise routine that would
run circles around Arnold Schwarzenegger
I don't think Paul Ryan could do this
this is totally an accurate RBG is gonna
live it forever
Lionel Hutz Esquire works on contingency
question mark no money down oh my god
this is one of my favorite episodes of
The Simpsons I don't know if the joke
comes through in text like this but I
think this is the episode where Lionel
Hutz represents Bart against the people
that make a jean Scratchy
they bring in an ad and it says Lionel
Hutz works on contingency no money down
and Lionel Hutz looks at it and says
coach they got this all screwed up it's
actually works on contingency question
mark no money down no money down I have
to do a reaction to Lionel Hutz at some
point he is such an amazing ridiculous
character in r.i.p Phil Hartman one of
the best cartoon voices of all time
sending emails to opposing counsel
thinking about the email I sent to
opposing counsel oh no this one hits
really close to home as a lawyer you're
constantly sending emails to opposing
counsel and we call them nasty grams
because they are very sternly worded
they are trying to get opposing counsel
to do something that they don't want to
do and you are negotiating on behalf of
your client so you have to put usually
an aggressive stance forward so it's
like you know granny holding a gun here
but then the minute that you send that
email to opposing counsel and you're
thinking about it you're probably gonna
go into your sent folder you're gonna
open up that email and you're gonna
check to see if there were any typos or
you said something stupid or you left a
word out it's just like this it will
cause an asthma attack or a panic attack
in so many different lawyers thinking
about the email that they sent as
opposed to the email that they they
intended to send that is definitely one
of the harder parts of being a lawyer is
stressing out over the stuff that you
sent to opposing counsel I feel it I
feel that approaching the jury without
permission be like yeah yeah the the
bailiff will tackle you if you get too
aggressive just like Jason Momoa is
doing with Henry Cavill here lawyer may
I approach the bench
judge you may lawyer walks up and
whispers that other guy's being like
super mean right now uh yeah yeah we
tend to be a little mean sometimes and I
can't tell you the number of times I
have litigated against I mean I'll say
they really just shoot themselves in the
foot because either the judge or the
jury doesn't like putting up with their
crap I understand the sentiment when the
other side is being mean and you know
you just want what's best for your
client all right do you swear to tell
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth me no judge governor's mic
what do I do I have never seen that
happen in court certainly would not help
your case if you are trying to get
people to believe your testimony
Kanye is ready to teach 1l contracts
kanye west we need consideration okay
this might take a second this is a
fantastic one el contracts joke so
there's a standard concept in contracts
that says you have to have consideration
for a valid contract consideration is
just something of value that is
exchanged between parties really what
it's done is to prevent people from
having what's called a gratuitous
contract where you write down a contract
but it's only the one side doing
something and the other side isn't
getting anything as a result so the
famous example is an uncle who tries to
contract with his nephew to go to
college and the uncle isn't necessarily
getting anything out of that but the the
law doesn't want to have enforceable
contracts where both sides don't get
something out of it and that thing is
called consideration so the fact that
Kanye is saying we need consideration
and then this person is saying that
Kanye is ready to teach 1el contract is
so funny me as a lawyer your honor
when does the Law & Order theme song
play or do we have to hum it ourselves
oh god I love Law & Order sadly it does
not play when you walk into a courtroom
dramatically when I was a kid my parents
had a strict limit on how much regular
TV I could watch I could only watch 30
minutes or an hour of TV a day but there
was no limit to how much educational TV
I could watch and I convinced them that
since I wanted to be a lawyer when I
grew up that I should be able to watch
law and order the series because that
would be educational TV I think I won
that argument and I was allowed to watch
reruns of Law & Order on TNT for
basically as long as I wanted that my
friends is some good lawyering right
there
[Music]
okay here we have a spongebob meme isn't
this a material fact judge yep and the
parties dispute this material fact judge
yep
the parties disagree about the material
fact therefore this issue should be
decided by the Trier of fact instead of
the judge judge that makes sense to me
so let's go to trial motion for summary
judgment granted this may not make sense
to everyone but this is absolutely
fantastic a summary judgment motion is
basically a trial on paper you submit
your best arguments and the other side
submits their best arguments and the
thing about a summary judgment motion is
that the factual basis must be
uncontested by both sides so if there is
an issue of material fact that both
sides disagree about you can't grant
summary judgment and it has to go to
trial that is great when you are a
defense lawyer like I tend to be but I
you know I've been on the other side of
that as well for on the plaintiff side
and it sucks when the judge grants
summary judgment against you imagine
spending seven years in college to
become a lawyer and your client shows up
to court like this I remember this this
was actually that long ago this is
takeshi 6 9 6 9 and he showed up to
court and I think it was convicted of a
gun related charge and I think he got
substantial jail time yeah you can't
show up to court like this now obviously
you're gonna swim upstream when your
face is covered in tattoos that is
definitely not going to put your best
face forward
yeah you can't show up with a ridiculous
tie like that with your shirt completely
untucked now obviously when you go to
court you have to wear a suit but I'm
not always in court as evidenced by this
actual video and when I'm not I'd love
to wear things like what I'm wearing
right now which is a polo from Mac
Weldon and it's hard to explain how soft
and light this polo is I absolutely love
it and I'm thrilled that Mac Weldon is
now a sponsor I'm also wearing their
world-famous boxer briefs right now but
I can't obviously show that to you well
unless hold on
yeah these are their their their famous
boxer briefs incredibly comfortable
supersoft I really like the pattern on
them as well here's a picture of me
wearing them this is definitely me
wearing them obviously I don't know why
the camera cut my head off there but
I've been thrilled with the Mack Weldon
shirts shorts and underwear that I
purchased from them and I've been
putting it through the wringer including
playing multiple hours of tennis in all
of the clothing and it has held up
beautifully and has stayed unbelievably
comfortable Mac Weldon is a men's
essential clothing brand that focuses on
smart design and premium fabrics and the
smart design goes beyond just the
clothing itself it goes into the website
when I had to order this polo with my
own money I had to get it shipped
expedited to arrive here in time for
VidCon and the process was incredibly
simple I ordered multiple sizes I had it
shipped overnight I tried on the clothes
I kept the ones that fit and I sent back
the ones that didn't using the included
return shipping label and it was a
wonderful experience Mac Weldon says
that their stuff is the most comfortable
underwear socks and other clothing that
you will ever wear and I think that is
totally reasonable so if you would like
20% off your first purchase from Mac
Weldon just go to Mac Weldon comm or use
the promo code legal eagle at checkout
again so for 20% off of your first
purchase from Mac Weldon go to Mac
Weldon comm and if you order a pair of
their famous boxer briefs and you don't
like it for any reason you can keep it
and they will still give you a refund
without sending it back because who
wants to get used underwear so do you
agree with my reviews of these legal
memes leave your objections in the
comments and of course check out this
playlist over here where I have all of
my other legal reactions including
reactions to lawyer jokes movies
television shows you name it so click on
the link and I will see you in court